في الحروب كل شيء مباح هكذا قالوا ويبدو
انهم صادقون
فكواليس حرب اوكرانيا باتت خير دليل على
الامانع ان يخفي حليف حرب معلومات لتفادي
حرب اكبر تتخطى حدود روسيا واوكرانيا
تقرير لصحيفه يورك تايمز كشف سلسله من
الخفايا التي تدور في اروقه الحرب وربما
كانت سببا رئيسيا لما وصلت اليه حاله
القوات الروسيه
على راس خفايا الحرب واشنطن وبحسب تقرير
صحيفه الامريكيه حاولت منعم مخطط اوكراني
لاغتيال رئيس الاركان الروسي فاليري جراسي
موف عبر حجمها معلومات عن الاوكرانيين تخص
زيارته للخطوط الاماميه للحرب
اخفاقات تكتيكيه ولوجسيه ايضا عانى منها
الجيش الروسي اذ وصف جنود تم الوصول اليهم
عبر الهاتف داخل المستشفيات الروسيه انه
تم ارسالهم الى الحرب بقليل من الطعام
والتدريب والرصاص وبمعدادات لا يعرفون
كيفيه استخدامها
اما الهواتف المحموله التي استخدمها
الجنود الروس للاتصال بدويهم فكانت سيفا
ذا حدين اذ مكن ذلك الجيش الاوكراني من
تحديد مواقعهم واستهدافهم ايضا ساهمت بعض
الانقسامات داخل القوات الروسيه بخلافات
وصلت الى حد استهداف قائد دبابه نقطه
تفتيش روسيا بشكل متعمد وفقا نيويورك
تايمز
تقرير قدم رؤا جديده للحرب الدائره منذ
شهور فمن خطط المعارك الروسيه السريه
والاعتراضات والمقابلات مع الجنود الروس
وصولا الى جهود الولايات المتحده لمنع حرب
مباشره